legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting and mobile
neither snow nor rain nor heat nor gloom
of night stays postal workers from their
jobs
but they never met president donald
trump and now is there a postal
conspiracy to slow down mail to affect
the 2020 election
2020 will go down in history as a year
dominated by the coronavirus pandemic
but in case you haven't noticed we also
have a major election coming up in just
a few short months
and covet 19 spreads easily between
people who are in close contact indoors
so states are scrambling for
alternatives to packing people into
polling places like
sardines and people are worried so this
has led to a shortage of poll workers
the best solution according to the
centers for disease control is to
increase
voting by mail and i have an entire
video devoted to voting by mail and the
potential for
mail fraud if there is one but
consistent with the cdc's recommendation
several states have expanded the ability
of voters to vote absentee or by mail
as a result of these changes a record 76
percent of american voters will be
eligible to receive a ballot in the mail
for the november 2020 election now it's
not entirely clear because he flip-flops
but it appears that president trump is
against voting by mail now they need
that money in order to have the post
office work so it can take all of these
millions and millions of ballots
but if they don't get those two items
that means you can't have universal
mail-in voting and we can only speculate
as to
why that is and into this mess jumped
new postmaster general lewis de joy the
man with the surname that sounds like it
should be a candy bar is making sweeping
changes at the postal service
these changes include reducing staff
taking away blue mailboxes prohibiting
overtime and raising postage on ballots
and throwing away mail sorters which
this reporter caught on video
we are at the usps patterson location
where behind me you can see a graveyard
of
mail sorting pieces they're just large
pieces of machinery that have been
yanked out in addition to that there's
also a dumpster
right there and according to an employee
that works across the way
they tell me that that dumpster has been
filled three times
since last week with parts and pieces
of what we're being told are the male
sorting
machines the postal service has now
warned that states may not be able to
deliver ballots in time for the november
election or deliver the ballots that are
in fact cast
and despite the fact that president
trump has tweeted that we should save
the post office
though not recognizing that he's sorted
the guy in charge it appears that
president trump is opposed to increasing
funding for the usps and ensuring that
ballots are delivered on time
coincidence or
conspiracy
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because the usps may hang in
the balance
today we're going to take a close look
at what's happening at the postal
service is
louis de joy deliberately trying to
impact the outcome of the election by
slowing down the mail
and if so can he be stopped but first
let's talk about the actual structure
of the us post office the usps delivers
40 percent of the world's mail
however kobit 19 caused a significant
reduction in lettermail which is the
most profitable mail process by the post
office
and the kovid 19 crisis could not have
happened at a worse time for the us post
office
the volume of letter mail has been
decreasing for quite some time mostly
due to the availability of email and
other options for communicating quickly
to understand the current issues we have
to review the basic legal structure of
the us post office
the post office was established in 1775
and the us post office was actually a
cabinet level agency until 1970
when congress passed the postal
reorganization act which established the
united states postal service as a
quasi-independent self-funded
organization
president george w bush signed the
postal accountability and enhancement
act in 2006.
the peya was the first broad revision of
the 1970 statute the paya imposed
several new requirements on how the
postal service is allowed to conduct
its business section 101 of the payette
defines postal service to mean the
delivery of letters printed matter or
mailable packages including acceptance
collection
sorting transportation or other
functions ancillary there too
this section of the law clarifies and
limits what the postal service can do
prior to this law the post office used
to sell things like prepaid phone cards
for example but
this practice ended after the paya
because the sale of prepaid phone cards
did not fit within this definition
this was good news for the post office's
competitors but bad news for the post
office's ability to self-fund
in section 102 of the law is a blanket
prohibition on
new products that aren't male several
postmaster generals have complained that
the postal service isn't permitted to
legally offer
banking cell phone logistics and other
services that postal services and other
countries use to generate the income
necessary to offset the costs of their
universal service obligation
senator bernie sanders has suggested
that the post office be allowed to
provide basic banking services postal
service can make billions of dollars a
year
by establishing basic banking services
so the lower income people have access
but this can't happen without
congressional intervention
under title ii of the paya the postal
service can only offer two categories of
products
market dominant products and competitive
products the postal service's market
dominant products
are include things like first class mail
letters first-class mail cards and
media mail with these monopolistic
products the usps can only
increase prices in accordance with the
consumer price index this keeps the
rates down for consumers but contributes
to the postal services insolvency
but given the usps has a monopoly on
these products there's a reason why you
don't necessarily want the prices to
increase too dramatically
but competitive products include those
for which a competitive market already
exists
those include things like priority mail
expedited mail and bulk parcel post
for these competitive products the post
office is barred from offering prices
lower than the cost of delivery so
this means that the usps can't undercut
fedex and usps by offering dramatically
lower prices that
are below the cost of actually
delivering and again this benefits
consumers but hurts the post office's
ability to fund itself or
offer lost leaders the paya also
established the postal service retiree
health benefits fund
section 801-803 of the paya changed the
usps from funding its retirees
healthcare costs on a pay-as-you-go
basis to pre-funding these obligations
the upshot of this is that the post
office had to create a 72 billion dollar
fund to pay for the cost of its
post-retirement healthcare costs
and the fact that the postal service has
to pre-fund its retirement obligations
from a separate account
hampers its financial prospects and this
pre-funding burden
applies to no other federal agency and
no private employer
now the paya also created the postal
regulatory commission
now the prc no relation has significant
powers but it also has to follow the
requirements of the administrative
procedures actor apa we've talked about
the apa a lot on this channel but it
governs the process by which federal
agencies develop regulations
it includes requirements for publishing
notices of proposed and final rulemaking
in the federal register
and provides opportunities for the
public to comment on notices of proposed
rulemaking the apa also requires most
rules to have a 30-day delayed effective
date
the apa provides standards for judicial
review if a person has been adversely
affected or aggrieved by an agency
action
so if the postal rate commission made
sweeping changes without following the
apa
and spoiler alert they did these changes
could be rolled back by a federal court
and as an assign a lot of people ask why
doesn't the postal service run
like a business and many people have
argued that the post office isn't
profitable
they claim that if it was any other
business like the trump taj mahal
it would have declared bankruptcy
because it couldn't turn a profit and in
fact
trump appointee richard grenell says
that the post office should just charge
you a lot more to send letters and
packages to make the usps profitable
and senator rand paul says that rural
citizens such as many of the people that
he represents in kentucky
should just settle for receiving the
mail just three days a week and
those changes could help make the postal
service more profitable but the postal
service has a legal mandate to provide
universal service to all u.s addresses
without charging more for
more costly delivery routes and this is
known as the universal
service obligation or uso the uso is not
clearly defined in legislation but it's
pieced together from numerous laws and
regulations and the basic obligations of
the postal service are defined in 39 usc
sections 101 and 403. these statutes
require the post office to provide a
range of product offerings maintain
uniform prices and availability
provide efficient services to people in
every geographic location in the u.s
and make its facilities accessible to
everyone congress gave the post office a
monopoly on mail service in exchange for
providing all of these service benefits
to the american people
uniformly in both price and service and
under 39 usc section 404-d
small post offices may not be quote
closed solely for operating at a deficit
if the post office was legally allowed
to operate like any other business
it could eliminate thousands of
unprofitable post offices in rural areas
it could cut services to rural citizens
it could only deliver the mail three
days a week and it could charge
much more for different service routes
now like many crises during the trump
era
these problems began long before
president trump took office
but the president has exploited some of
these issues and accelerated them
the board of governors of the usps is
responsible for overseeing the
activities of the postal service
while the postmaster general actively
manages its day-to-day operations
a postmaster general is not appointed by
the president instead the board of
governors chooses a new person only when
there is a vacancy
and the board of governors is designed
to be as non-partisan as possible
for this reason no more than five
members can be members of the same
political party however right now there
are only six members of the board of
governors and all six of them were
appointed by president trump the other
vacancies have not been filled
presumably because
president trump is required by law to
appoint democrats the board of governors
has not been fully staffed since
2010 because senate republicans refused
to confirm
five nominees by president obama in
april the usps notified congress that it
was running out of money and in may
republican donor louis de joy was named
postmaster general by the now
six members of the board of governors
president trump asked his nominees who
were the only people on the board
to appoint dejoy they did so despite his
lack of experience at the postal service
he's the first postmaster general ever
to have zero experience with the usps he
was most recently the financial chairman
of the republican national committee
de joy hasn't divested himself of his
financial holdings in a logistics
company that does business with the
postal service he also went out and
purchased amazon stock after his
nomination as postmaster general which
is a potential red flag for conflict of
interest
and speaking of amazon the company does
have a great deal with the usps
the retail giant focuses its own
delivery network on densely populated
urban areas which keeps its costs low
however this means that the postal
service which is required to serve
everyone
effectively winds up subsidizing amazon
delivery to low population density areas
the address is that it wouldn't be
profitable for amazon to deliver to
which coincidentally are very very red
counties
across the country and ironically
republicans including president trump
have criticized the amazon deal as being
bad for business
and in spite of or perhaps because of
this relationship with amazon
president trump has disagreed with
various democratic proposals to increase
funding for the post office
so let's talk about the recent changes
that de joy brought to the u.s postal
service
on july 10th dejoy announced a major
operational pivot
which imposes new significant
restrictions on the timing and nature of
letter carrier routes
dejoy admitted that this would cause
delays in a memo where he said we may
see mail left behind or mail
on the workroom floor which is not
typical and just to be clear dejoy also
says he didn't make any of these
controversial changes
could you please tell me who did order
these changes if us postmaster general
did not there were many many executives
almost
uh 30 000 executives within the
organization
and there were plans that existed prior
to my arrival that will continue that
were implemented
but postal workers have been trained not
to leave letters behind and make
multiple trips to ensure timely
distribution of the mail
this is why they sometimes make
unscheduled deliveries or deliver mail
on a sunday the joy now says that
carriers should leave this male behind
for the next day which may accumulate
and pile
up as time goes on in addition letter
carriers are now prohibited from sorting
mail in the morning and delivering it in
the afternoon
instead they will get to the routes
earlier in the morning and then return
to their posts
to sort mail in the afternoon and some
of these policies directly affect
ballot delivery on july 29th the usps
general council announced a policy
change directly targeting ballots
the letters said that the ballot sent by
marketing mail would not be accorded
first class mail treatment and thus
take longer to deliver the postal
service had previously trained its
employees to give first-class treatment
to balance and any other
election-related materials
sent as marketing mail this change
imposes much bigger financial burdens on
states
which will now have to pay 55 cents per
piece for first class delivery
rather than the 20 cents per piece they
previously paid states are already
anticipating huge increases in requests
for ballots this comes at a time when
state budgets are completely in shambles
because of covet 19.
in addition postal clerks can no longer
provide a witness signature
on ballots in some states you need a
third party witness when you sign
a mailed ballot and the ballots
typically say that voters can simply go
to the post office and have a
worker watch them sign that this
practice is now
ended and one of the most baffling
measures has been the decommissioning of
10
of the mail sorting machines at postal
service centers these machines can sort
30 000 pieces of mail per
hour and although de joy said that he
would stop doing this they've already
decommissioned
95 of the machines that were planned to
be disconnected
in august dejoy ordered the postal
service to remove 671 mail sorting
machines by the end of september
including 24 in ohio 11 in detroit 11 in
florida nine in wisconsin eight in
philadelphia
and five in arizona what's interesting
about these states is that these just
happen to be
states which are expected to decide the
outcome of the presidential election
and dejoy who claims he didn't make
these changes has a firm opinion on
whether he would ever reverse them
mr dejoy will you commit to reversing
these changes no these actions have
already spurred nationwide mail delays
in mail collection mail sorting and mail
delivery at a mail processing facility
in santa clarita in july workers
discovered that their automated sorting
machines had been disabled and padlocked
at a large mail sorting facility in los
angeles workers told the la times that
they are so far behind processing
packages that
by early august nats and rodents were
swarming around containers of rotted
fruit and meat
and a brief warning to animal lovers
there were even some packages containing
small animals which perished in their
boxes
in southeast washington dc residents
have gone weeks without receiving any
mail
people have medical supplies that are
delivered by the mail
they have utility bills they have
important financial documents
which they are not receiving and i can
say personally that
one of the mailboxes that has been in my
own neighborhood
in washington dc which has been there
for
years if not decades was recently
removed just a few weeks ago and
i've never received an explanation why
there have been many reports of veterans
and elderly citizens who rely
on male delivery of their medication
going through delays and
entire native american tribes in
california haven't received mail for
weeks
so not surprisingly this has created all
kinds of legal battles
voters states advocacy groups and
candidates are suing the trump
administration over changes at the
postal service
the naacp filed a lawsuit against dejoy
and trump the naacp's main cause of
action is the postal service ignored the
postal reorganization act by
failing to seek an advisory opinion from
the prc
under 39 usc section 3661 before
implementing changes that have a
nationwide impact on mail delivery
the postal service has to provide an
opportunity for public comment and seek
an
advisory opinion from the postal rate
commission the opinion may not issue
until the commission provides an
opportunity for a public hearing and
here it's undisputed that the postal
service failed to do so with respect to
either the pivot or the change in
treatment of ballots sent by marketing
mail
and congress also mandates that the
postal service shall give the highest
consideration to the requirement for the
most expeditious collection
transportation and delivery of important
letter mail
the naacp argues that the postal
service's reversal of its policy of
according first class
service to ballots sent by marketing
mail is inconsistent with that statutory
mandate
and it's also obvious that dejoy's
changes violated the apa
the biggest question is whether a court
will order him to reverse course and
remediate the steps that have already
been taken others argue that this
violates the elections clause and the
electors clause of the constitution
pennsylvania maine california delaware
the district of columbia massachusetts
and north carolina have filed a lawsuit
against the federal government
raising many of the same claims as the
naacp in addition the states allege that
detroit's actions are unconstitutional
under the elections clause
the constitution's elections clause
vests authority in the states to
regulate the quote time place and manner
of holding elections for senators and
representatives that will
represent the state but only congress
may displace how a state has chosen to
regulate the time place in manner of a
federal election
the constitution's electors clause vests
authority in the states to appoint
quote a number of electors equal to the
whole number of senators and
representatives
to which the state may be entitled in
congress
the plaintiff states here allege that
they have exercised these rights by
expanding voting by mail
when they passed legislation that
expanded vote by mail they relied on the
postal service's long history in
delivering election mail in a timely
manner
they contend that dejoy's abrupt changes
interfere with the constitutional power
given to the states to control their own
elections
and other alleged violations of the 1st
and 14th amendments
certain voters have sued the trump
administration and detroit's actions
arguing that they are being denied their
right to vote
in these suits the plaintiffs allege
that the way that de joy is managing the
postal service
will stop some voters from voting at all
which would be a severe burden
plaintiffs include people who have
medical conditions that make kopit 19
especially dangerous and
people who live in remote areas and
cannot travel long distances to vote in
person
and theoretically if burton would
essentially deny a person the right to
vote then
it could be considered unconstitutional
though others would argue that
everyone faces some burden in voting
it's simply a
spectrum here but the plaintiffs in
these suits say that the government
doesn't have any real state interest in
making the dramatic changes
and the only interest that postmaster de
joy has identified is cost saving and
efficiency
plaintiffs argue that while cost saving
is important in government in many ways
it's settled law that constitutional
rights cannot be taken away because it's
too expensive to grant them
in addition the postal service's mandate
to serve as an affordable public service
seems to clash with the idea that cost
savings should interfere with
constitutional rights
the plaintiffs also note that the
president's stated justification for
denying post office funding
his own political fortunes is obviously
not the kind of legitimate government
interest that would justify a burden on
voters and candidates
but some of the damage has already been
done and unfortunately the courts will
be relatively slow to act
and reports continue that the postal
service is removing blue postal boxes
all over the country
if you see this happening you should
report it immediately and to do that
you'll need really good cell coverage
and ting mobile is just the cellular
service to report governmental
misconduct
team provides great lte coverage because
it partners with the biggest carriers so
you get the benefit of three massive
networks wherever you go
no matter which part of the state you
live in and these days the smartphone
with the camera is the greatest tool we
have against government oppression
and ting mobile lets you send those
videos of government corruption
quickly and efficiently because ting
mobile is a different kind of mobile
provider
with ting you only pay for the actual
data and services that you use at the
end of the month and because you're
paying for only what you actually use
ting customers pay on average just 23
dollars per month for one device
and with ting you can use almost any
cell phone including the newest iphones
and pixel phones and you can use the
same phone number you're using right now
there's no contract overage fees or any
other carrier tricks you just pay
a fair price for the talk text and data
that you use up at the end of the month
and ting has award-winning customer
support because they don't have any
brick-and-mortar stores
they pour all their resources into their
phone and online support if you have any
issues you can just
pick up the phone call them and
immediately talk to a real human being
with ting especially if you're around
wi-fi all the time which most of us are
considering we're working from home
which is why we need to vote by mail in
the first place
you end up paying less than you do now
of course some people should pay 200
a month for unlimited data if they're
nowhere near their homes or wi-fi
but if you're surrounded by a wi-fi
network all day long you might be paying
hundreds of dollars more completely
unnecessarily
and ting gives you the option to pay
only for what you use
so if you go to legaleagle.ting.com you
can use your last bill to compare just
how much you would save
and legal eagles will get a 25 credit by
going to legaleagle.ting.com
and that could cover your entire first
month of service and since there are no
contracts you can try it for a month no
strings attached again all you have to
do is click on the link in the
description
or go to legaleagle.ting.com and get a
25
credit for whatever service you want
plus clicking on that link really helps
out this channel
so do you agree with my analysis do you
think that the usps
is being destroyed from the inside leave
your objections in the comments and
check out the playlist over here with
all of my other
real law reviews talking about all of
the crazy things that's happening in the
government
on the run up to election so that's fun
so
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court